it's time get your ways clear your mind
breathe in breathe out
control your breathing use your
diaphragm
that's your pathway it's a long windy
road like that goofy ass rolled
over in San Francisco that's how your
intestines are shaped you go
through your rectum to vector
that's a medical term for your ass hole
let yourself fall away I'm gonna
take you on an amazing journey we're
gonna go in a body you see trust
me you don't trust me you wanna call you
in spoken
he was outspoken you were saying hey
well taking me yet
destination we closed eyes you see a
medal and stream from
flowers and ah I love it it's
beautiful is trampled and then you open
your eyes you ain't in no mental
they know scream over there you still
[Music]
the left stream is and washing
machine you hit a water going in and
cutting and washing machine because that
couch you sleep one in that
basement
it's right next to the laundry
room stupid-ass brother
there's always watching his goddamn
sneakers and he dries his goddamn goofy
ass stinks never try
[Laughter]
sneakers oh my god your dryer
just took you out of your self
calm the down
[Music]
so to ourselves close trust a
process keep breathing in through your
nose
[Music]
out to your ass into your nose out to
your ass I know for the stop I stopped
breathing
[Music]